I was always conscious that what my job
was from Manchester nated so I was
prepared to risk whenever we didn't
matter with the next year am I taught
anyone could play a game of football
anyone the practice makes you a real
football you know wave is devoted to
being the best it can be
fear is not a problem how you deal with
a problem and if you don't deal with
that then you'll feel again I think of
it energy and it's in any when wasn't -
this is very important I think that the
example was saying it was important to
them say well if he can do I can do it
people don't respond to change well when
they see someone a manager bit he's
changing his mind every second day or
your attitude should be I've got my
chance I'm in this world I'm going to
succeed you say to yourself well could I
be that way that you know what 27 years
in prison color and have no business at
all he's a former Scottish football
manager and player who managed
Manchester United he's regarded as one
of the greatest football managers of all
time during his 26 years as Manchester
United he won 38 trophies he's Sir Alex
Ferguson and here are his top ten rules
for success how would a chief executive
manage risk for a football coach I was
always conscious that what my job was
from Manchester nated so I was prepared
to risk shove defenders up in the
attacking positions take the gun because
you always do nothing and still was -
anyway you know I think there's a common
sense attitude from from good widows
that as a worth the risk but are we
going to lose her to this well I think
that United were the best art they were
best serve in the consistency whenever
we didn't matter with the next year in
my talks and there's nobody teams can
continue without for instance city when
the week was the next where next year
Chelsea over the spell I know them the
bad spell it's very difficult to
maintain a success I can continue
successful five six seven years very
very difficult and what was the thing
that
allowed you to do it where so many other
people have had challenges doing that
whether they're running a company or
running a football club well as as that
complacency to avoid complacency that if
we went a week my first steps the next
season was to remain them about many
things of expectation of a
responsibility that complacency is a
disease that all these things matter to
me because I was always fearful of
dropping back off the scale and false
way we had them we were a reasonable
consistency but the most important thing
the United for me was that every time we
lost the week and the prima divisione we
went in the next year so there was a
response by the character of the team
that was really important development
character and the football team this is
important is developing the stability of
the team and the character that football
Cobb was very very strong very strong
characters and I think that is really
important the advice I give to any young
kid as anyone can play a game of
football anyone the practice makes you a
real football
you see games in a Sunday pub games Oh
what I gave a football the real players
of the practice I think about and where
you take that I've never been a lunch in
Glasgow many many years ago and Gary
Player was a classical golfer and they
asked him a question why do you keep
practicing from the bunker because it
was famous for girls bunker says well I
know I'm going to be the in the bunker
at one time in the game maybe twice in a
game and I've got to put in a hole is
that's why I practice and practice and
practice that's a great example of we
have to do to be a job where other
sacrifices you have to make as a leader
I think I read in your book that you you
played football the day you got married
they missed the
one of your sons at least what do you
have to make these sacrifices to be a
winning chief executive absolutely
there's no other way
yes your wave is devoted to being the
best it can be
and also an example to everyone so a
sacrifice is absolute its Parliament
absolute to me absolute Parliament I've
got the achievements that aren't that
big what all know and feel it's not a
problem how you deal with a problem and
if you don't deal with that then you'll
feel again I always feel that adversity
is always driving Manchester nated on we
don'twe losing and therefore the human
beings we've gone near that character
we've got in the dress room has to come
to the surface and moments were voiced
again to think of it energy and it's in
any when wasn't to this is very
important when you stop wave identity
natives we see it 43 44 years of age
they see the energy the Piercy then you
see bonus and oye but when you get to
the sixes they still expect to see it so
I look at myself in terms of energy that
it was a slept because when I was a
young major four or five years no
problem when I got to that to is my 60s
and either six or seven hours so you go
to bed err where you work it your your
diet better sardine eat swallow after
the game on home you know I never a very
very seldom learners Alan eight so that
added things I myself over my energy
because people want to see the energy
very important aspect of it if you were
running a business and it was a business
winning team what characteristics would
you have to see my staff and WA see them
come in yellow in the morning I thought
it was good ready fresh but it seemed
purposes me hard-working energetic good
personalities and we built a bigger
staff in terms of the physiotherapists
and sports sciences and things of that
these started coming to seem tame as me
so I think that the example was saying
there was important to
I'm saying well if you can do I can do
it I think the important thing is to
what I think is really important to be
consistent be who you are don't change I
think people don't respond to change
well when they see someone a manager bit
it's changing his mind every second day
or whatever I think consists is a really
important I don't think they should
whatever the number of people call Phi
the same time ISM that's way negative
you know that thing is here should apply
all of the hundreds of play I'll never
get it you know I don't think that's a
positive attitude your attitude should
be I've got my chance somewhere in this
world I'm going to succeed and want to
pay for the job you know something which
is really important for a young person
get as many interviews you can you know
that technique of going for an interview
is nothing only you know even get 100
interviews you feel natan any things
you'll improve through interviewing and
at some point in a way if you may have
interview someone else you're a great
student of leaders historical political
who are some of the leaders you admire
them for what qualities Nelson Mandela a
great thing about them was that was
absent all bitterness and is attached to
his life and you say to yourself or
could I be that way that you know 27
years in prison
color and have no business at all was
interesting was making South Africa a
country to be recognized and growing a
moral path
thank you so much for watching I made
this beauty because high/low asked me to
so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Sir
Alex Ferguson's top 10 rules had the
biggest impact on you leave it in the
comments and I'll join the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
over the bar in the second possibly
filling that you said a couple of very
good chances hasn't taken either
interest to a torn over no doubt mother
will defending bravely still nothing
each is a quantum of thoughts inflaming
going up yours therefore mother wall as
he's been so often asking the mother
will defense positively racing out now
becomes across purposes they're
practicing his score
my tickle has a
mostly we ought to look at the linesman
most of a picture of the linesman to our
right
this conversation should certainly be
interesting
rightfully coming over to the linesman
ladies when talking to the rave
this is official moment in this match
so Alex Ferguson's ball is good
the ball came across
Ferguson last eluded the defense there
he has wait in the middle of your
picture
and with five minutes to play a
controversial goal
but one counts air United lead by one
goal to nil on Alec Ferguson scores the
sixth goal of the season